with a possible recession nearing what
can you do to protect your home pip
lending the sponsors of this next
segment they have the answers let's
welcome andrew levitt and vanessa gomez
good to see you guys thank you how is
pif landing different from the other
guys out there uh you know we have a lot
of experience what we can do differently
is we all sell to the same person at the
end of the day fannie or freddie fha
essentially and we just know how to get
through the guidelines and help someone
get qualified you guys been doing it for
a while i've got experience which which
is what i like vanessa so a possible
recession coming it does happen can that
cause someone's loan to fall through
yes because with recessions crashing or
falling the interest rate continues to
go up so if someone was approved at one
dollar amount with that charge going up
and increasing that dollar amount is
going to continue to go lower and lower
and then they may not find the home that
they were looking for originally okay so
how do you guys protect your customers
or clients from that happening to them
so one of the features that we have is
we can lock a rate six months into the
future so that way if we lock it today
we keep that qualification intact while
they're shopping for that house you guys
have the answer six months in advance
yeah this is what you have the abortion
dollars i love this
moving buying a home i mean it's
stressful it's the whole process it's a
wonderful process but there's also so
much stress that comes into it how do
you help alleviate some of that stress
you know one of the things that we do is
that we do all the underwriting up front
so my background prior to sales was
working in underwriting and so we get
all of their documents we make sure that
we go through everything with the fine
tooth comb and that way we avoid a lot
of the issues in the middle of the
process so everything is locked in
pretty much with you guys so i'm going
to buy my house i'm working with pif
lending i know that everything's secure
i have to worry about we're getting
ready to close and oh what's this little
blemish here or something's not taken
care of correct
and then we basically when it comes to
something of that sort it's because that
one requirement that we needed up front
maybe just didn't make it in on time and
that's really the only issue that we've
ever run into so it's never can we do it
or can't we we can it's just timing is
sometime could go on the client side
especially the third parties involved
like the appraisers and all the facets
that are involved there are so many
people involved there's so many people
involved the name pip lending what does
it mean i'll pay it forward okay
so long story short there's been a lot
of people that have helped me and get
the company going just in general and
some of them i'll never be able to repay
and so what we get to do moving forward
is you know pay it back and you're a
vegas born vegas raised guy here
absolutely refinancing still a good time
to refinance your home
yeah i would say yes especially if
you're looking to do some cash out take
the equity while it's there at the
moment and uh use it for reserves or
liquid assets just in case for a rainy
day or emergency rate
shopping yeah thank you guys so much i
can chat with you for an hour about this
so thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it pif lending is located at
4155 south buffalo drive suite 101 for
more information call
702-800-4664 or visit
payetfordlending.com and they have a
special offer if you call them and
mention las vegas now they will make an
appraisal waiver for new clients las
vegas now we will be right back